by a vote of nine
to zero bailey you are evicted from the
big brother house
all right bailey how are you feeling
about
being sent home right now everybody
was asking me as i was you know
eliminated if i was okay
and i really truly am like i feel
honored to have been a part of the
all-star cast
i feel honored that they decided to
evict me before jury started
i'm blessed okay i know you wanted to go
in there and you wanted to prove that
you could play this game
do you feel like you proved that
absolutely i feel like i played the game
and i'm very happy with the way i
conducted myself in the house well of
course we saw everything get
heated between you and davon and
christmas
this just started right now what
happened i don't know she's out there
arguing
because of you there is personal game
information no such thing as personal
game information
personal information is what happens in
real life game information
is what happens in the game and you
exposed her right i explained
because you guys are a duo you we
weren't a duo
well she says that you're her
untouchable so what the am i supposed to
do with that information christmas i'm
gonna walk away
i'm gonna walk away thank you i'm gonna
walk away good night i'm not going to
bed don't goodnight me but i'll have a
good night i'm gonna
walk don't worry my door will be locked
away how are you feeling emotionally
about that fight as you sit here today
you know what if
devon and i were to do what christmas
did this is how we would be labeled and
if you know she were to you know
she just has a different standard when
it comes to these things so the
conversations we had
were very healthy and i feel like the
the fight needed to happen
um and i hope that eventually christmas
sees you know the difference between
the way she conducts herself in the way
that we conduct ourselves in the double
standard there
get your fingers out of my head back up
and get your fingers out of my face
because i'm talking calmly and you want
to yell
i didn't treat you like this so why are
you treating me this way i'm coming out
really really
you do not think she understands that
she doesn't she does not i know for a
fact she doesn't but i know that when
she
gets out of this house we're gonna have
a phone call and she will
do you plan to talk to her one-on-one
absolutely i do
because because for me it's important
for people to learn from these
experiences
so what we're going to do is we're going
to sit down and we're going to talk it
through and let me make you understand
where we're coming from what do you want
to say to her if there's one thing
um there's multiple things christmas and
i had a conversation where she calls her
alter ego
to wanda which okay i get it
but do you understand what that means to
me as a person and what that says
that that's number one so i want to talk
to her about that and just kind of about
respecting people's space and what i'm
offended by is that i've had this
conversation with you beforehand and
then you still put me in that
compromising
position and if you respected someone
you would not do that to someone
especially knowing the burden that they
carry
and the time that we're in so yeah i
definitely will have a conversation with
christmas about it there was a
conversation where christmas said she
was afraid
she was going to get shot about who she
was putting up
i i wanted to get your thoughts on that
you know what
this is my first time hearing it so i
was not aware but you know what
that was the vibe that we were getting
and so i'm so glad
that it was shown and that it was seen
because a lot of the times when we talk
about these things people are like oh
you're just bringing rice into it
oh you always pull that card no these
are things that we feel and we can
we have evidence that this is how people
you know
are behaving and this is what they're
saying i'm so happy that day and i
you know handled the way handed
ourselves the way that we did
because we could have blown up we could
have been angry but that's what she
wanted and i would not give
her that good game bailey why what did i
do
you literally did nothing she betrayed
you and she
bowed it she betrayed you when she met
you did nothing but i
tried to calm her down did nothing at
this point the fight that you guys had
this argument between the three of you
is the moment of the season you know it
was compelling to watch
in in ways where we're all kind of
looking at ourselves and looking at the
way that people communicate in moments
like that
what have you taken away about yourself
from that one so much growth
because bb 20 bay would have would have
ran circles around that girl
so that i've grown um two that i
represent something that's so much more
that's so much bigger than me
so it's very important for me to keep my
composure in moments like that
um and that three is that the world
needed to have this conversation
so i'm grateful for everything in the
way that it played out because these are
conversations we need to have there's so
many you know what i've learned is that
there's a lot of conversations that
have never been addressed because people
don't feel comfortable having them
so now there is a platform there are
people that are willing and ready to
speak about this
and that can properly explain the way
that you know we feel
in these kind of emotion-heavy times so
i'm
i'm grateful and i'm happy and i'm i'm
here to
you know have this conversation as long
as it needs to be had what message would
you have for fans about how they
look at christmas moving forward i know
how the fans are
so part of me wants to be like yeah tear
her up but
part of me also is like she's a human
um and she's ignorant to her own
ignorance she doesn't even know
that what she's doing is wrong so i'm
gonna take the moment
and educate her you know what i'm saying
it's we're in a canceled culture i know
y'all want to cancel her she's probably
already canceled
but for me i have to say
okay if i don't teach her she's never
going to learn and then she's going to
walk around scared
you know that everybody of color people
of color are going to attack her
so she's lucky that i'm nice and i will
take the time
to hug her rub her back let her cry but
i'm gonna i'm gonna explain it to her
when you were voted out you i think you
said something to christmas you
whispered something to her what did you
say to her
um i just told her that it was okay
that was literally it i'm like hey it's
okay
because and you know what i really did
this is and this is
when i kind of realized it when we gave
our speeches
christmas christmas face literally was
almost discolored because
i don't think she even realized what she
did
until it was done so she's gotta she's
gonna have some
awareness to just wash over her
oh i know she's i know for a fact she's
literally gonna be shook
do you think that christmas can be
redeemed and do you think that tyler can
be redeemed
um i hope so
there are moments where you're like okay
this person is really really cool
so i hope that christmas takes
responsibility
instead of plays the i've been attacked
on the victim card
then she moves forward because that's
the only choices she has the problem is
that when people do things like this and
then they deny it
or they don't take responsibility that's
where we get into backsliding territory
as far as tyler
um he's no longer my responsibility my
my hands are are done with that what do
you think about tyler's true
intentions at this point i was gonna ask
christmas if she could
use a veto on one of you and put me up
because i owe you guys that and i think
you guys can do better
and i think you deserve better and
you're standing for something
you know like greater than me and i want
to see that
i want to see that play out what was it
like hearing him say that
you and day had this bigger purpose in
the house and then finding out
that he you know didn't follow through
about using the veto well it was a
mixture it was a slap in the face
because he knows how important this is
um
and he knew that he was covered i don't
feel like she ever would have
used it or put him up even if he begged
her for it since i know that they're not
you know playing the game together it
just wasn't going to happen
but i do think that he had good
intentions and i do felt think he felt
really guilty for the things that he was
doing
and so he had to clear his conscience
but i think the conscience clearing was
more for him
and less for us so do you think he was
using
this summer and the black lives matter
movement
to his advantage in the game in my heart
of hearts i just
i really cannot believe that anybody
would stoop that low so if he did that
is so unfortunate that is so unfortunate
but that's that's that's low do you
think that he believes in the black
lives matter movement
yeah i think he does i think he does i
just think he made a very
poor choice of character judgment by
using it as something that to be
manipulated in the game
the fact that he made it kind of even a
questionable joke
was bad judgment on his part so i think
he's gonna have a lesson to learn too
when he gets out of here
um and he can convince everybody else
who do you feel more betrayed by between
those two
honestly i'm i'm gonna have to say still
tyler like christmas i just met her she
didn't really owe me anything tyler it's
been years and years and so many text
messages
he had angela texting swaggy you know
the personal lines that he
the links that he'll go to they just
don't end so for me it's like don't tell
me that you love me don't tell me
you know okay i have you know your
significant other
talking mind i would never do that i
would never use black lives matter and
then still
say things you know like she's pulling
the race card she's a sucky player
you're it's it's it's come on come
on so it's just disappointing
i'm sensing the hurt in your voice are
are you and tyler done
i think we might have to be it's
literally like how many times can i
forgive you when you're the one who hurt
me in the first place
i'm gonna step back i'm gonna step back
would you be willing to have a
conversation with him
uh like you plan to with christmas out
of here or is that chapter closed
you know it's crazy i don't know what's
wrong with me
i am open my heart is just open you know
so if
he wants to have a conversation and he
needs to talk about it yeah he can call
me he has my number
let's talk about those eviction speech
speeches uh in her speech devon used
that moment
to talk about black lives matter still
screaming justice for brianna taylor and
every other black life that has been
taken
unjustly and unfairly be simply because
of the color of their skin
all lives can't matter until black lives
matter and that includes black trans
lives as well
what was going through your mind as you
were sitting there i'm so grateful for
this bond because it's like she's in my
head so
she's hitting points and i'm like yes
yes yes because
what people need to realize is that even
coming into
into this game this was so much bigger
than us this was
okay how can we turn down an opportunity
to be on a
national platform in the middle of a
controversial heat like this like
our people are suffering we're going
through this you know
experience together and it's our job to
be able to represent that so we came in
here
with intentions to represent and
represent well and i believe that we did
and we had to bring it all the way full
circle back to why we're standing here
we are there
because of you know black lives matter
because of
just because of our cause so remember
why you're in the house and
she nailed it and for me i wanted to
touch down on the fact that
they want us to fight normally black
women are are put in situations where
there's only room for one of us and they
want us at each other's throat
and that's not the case i will always
support her i will be her number one fan
you know behind cadence but i am i'm
there for her so i'm just
so grateful that her and i are on the
same page and i'm grateful that you know
it was heard do you think sitting here
now you realized
when you were going in the house how big
this moment might be
and and how do you feel about it now yes
i
i feel like i knew the moment was going
to be big i would have rather it
have been final two you know and not
next to each other on the block that was
our plan
um but regardless the job was done so
whether we were sitting final two and we
could have those speeches then
or whether we were sitting next to each
other and one of us is leaving
the the conversation was had and i think
people saw you know
the hurt and the passion and you know
every the conviction behind our cause
what love do you want to send through
the screen today right now as she
continues to be
your your girl in there and your
representation in there and your
your untouchable forever friend in there
forever
literally our first instagram picture
together will say my untouchable
forever but i just want to send her
just so much love and so much like
support
i feel so proud of her she's such a
great representation of
black women everywhere and just strong
women period regardless of color
she is an amazing mom she's hating a
great example for cadence
i want her to push through because she
still has a chance she really does in
this game
one thing i love is that the power
shifts so when it shifts
she's going to be on the right side of
it
what do you think about danny being the
new hoh what will she do with that
oh i didn't know you just told me oh
you know what i think she'll come for
uh david and kevin and i hope she
doesn't touch day if she touches day
danny is lame she's canceled
unsubscribed
backspace delete would you play this
game again
yes always and forever big brother has a
special place in my heart
but um next time maybe i'll do it as a
celebrity
okay yes and my last question for you
what do you want
the fans to take away from you being in
the house this season what do you want
your message
to them to be i really really want the
fans to take away that
it's a different game for some some of
us out there and that the playing
field really needs to be leveled so we
need your help well we love you
and uh we have loved watching you i
would love to watch you again
um and thank you so much for uh for
taking us on this journey with you and
for setting the example you set
and going deep thank you
[Music]